oh he's at it again
[Music]
once upon a time back in round one he
had the lakers being swept
by portland wow you know how that turned
out and now
put that main check up sweet
man there is no stopping the man inside
the nba
presented by kia comes your way next
highlights and we we do have a little
gone fishing we still haven't seen the
team fishing
no it's been more than one there's no
stopping
you can't even contain
i knew it wouldn't take long for a
social to jump
there you go oh that's a turbo right
there there you go
p street habitual ymca
most exercise you got no oh come on
why is there always access to a broom
hey
um there's so many problems we got
plenty
around here girl
i did have to look for approval i'm not
going to lie i wouldn't want close by
we broke about a dozen of them that
other night that is a nasty what does
that mean chuck
oh it's quick and painless brother
freaking painters
i gotta get my travel agent it's uh
friday inside the nba presented
friday sunday tuesday thursday
all right you know what next friday is
one two three
[Laughter]
way too early for that yeah yo we
thought
we thought it was crazy that uh that you
went they'd win it in five
with a guarantee well and now and now
you go to the sweep after one game
number one the best case scenario
dembele can win a game
but they got no advantages ernie it's
all about matchups
and i told you against the clippers
joker just was too big for them
he's not too big for the white and
anthony davis
and that was the difference jamal even
if jamal plays well
joker's going to have his hands full
with dwight and athlete every game
by the way dwight howard played more
minutes tonight than he did in the
entire houston
series as the lakers took game one
and we take a gander at the highlights
here
got them beats all
let's see what the nuggets can do after
coming back in consecutive series from
3-1 deficits and it was a good start for
murray there
oh back denver led after one quarter
38-36 rondo was big ernie he was really
big his passing is
getting into the lane finding the right
people keeping the tempo correct when
lebron was
out the game murray stepping back cashew
out
and they're up as i said 38-36 after one
but then the lakers
start the second quarter 17-1.
too big dominated the starter every four
too big too strong
oh sidestep mark morris shooting the
lights out the ball
draymond anybody in the league right now
has the same athleticism that lebron has
at this
like that kept it this long that you can
think of that you played against i don't
think there's anybody
in nba history that kept up this long
okay all right
i was like maybe i'm missing somebody i
don't know when he's not doing that he's
doing this
bully ball too little that that was bad
coverage from the start
70 to 59 at the half lakers
and then early in the third they put
together a 16-4
run this is
everybody in the basketball world knew
if anthony davis was the second best
player
on the court the lakers were going to
win the championship we knew that
seven months ago oh a year ago now
howard had 13 on
four of five played good defense they
gave up two minutes
in the third quarter alone the lakers
advantage and points in the paint was 20
to 6.
yeah that's when the lakers really put
it on them
a lot of high percentages are getting
carried away trying to get brand new
lives
oh get out of here get out of here
little fella
oh jump welcome
check this out
oh come on now oh you know i know it's
tough today man just out there playing
horse brother oh
you know the lakers were in the bubble
in the regular part they were struggling
but
when rondo came back yeah they just took
off
five everybody five and one
he just put everybody in the right place
not saying he's the best player but he
puts everything
i'm sure hope you're not saying that i
mean it just makes me feel like
there's never a time where they don't
have a flood general yep
don't be deceived by that final score so
a 12 point game it was a
a 27 point lead at one point paid me two
kid
and uh the lakers take game one 126
to 114.